Hallo, ich bin Herr Karra. Ich bin auf der Station Aarstein-Erz tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das auch noch mit dem Gespräch führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Verstehen Sie mich? Ist das soweit okay? Ob Sie mich soweit verstehen?
Ein bisschen, ich kann nichts hören.
Stimme, kommt alles gut an oder ist das undeutlich?
Können Sie lauter sprechen?
Also, ich bin auch nicht so ganz glücklich.
Können Sie mich jetzt besser?
Jetzt besser.
Okay, Ihre Name war noch mal Dr. Karra.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Klaus-Jürgen Müller.
Können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren, bitte?
Klaus-Jürgen Müller. Man muss nicht immer alles buchstabieren, aber ich versuche mal.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sie das bisher immer gemacht haben.
Buchstabieren kann man auch z.B. mit anderen Namen oder Städtenamen,
weil einfach vom Buchstaben zu sagen ist manchmal auch undeutlich.
Also, K-L-A-U-S-Klaus und Jürgen mit J-U-R-G-E-N.
Und Müller, W-M-U-L-L-E-R.
Ja.
J-U-L-Müller.
Jürgen Müller. Klaus-Jürgen Müller.
Okay, danke.
Und jetzt möchte ich einige allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ist das genug?
Ich hatte am Anfang nur nicht richtig verstanden.
Sie sind im Krankenhaus oder Sie sind in der Praxis.
Wie war das nochmal?
Ich bin nicht im Krankenhaus jetzt.
Sie sind Assistenzarzt oder sind Sie als Allgemeinmediziner in der Praxis?
Ich bin Assistenzarzt und ja, für Allgemein.
In einem Krankenhaus.
Okay, gut. Dann versteht es.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,75 m groß und wiege ungefähr 85 kg.
Wie wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ja, das ist der 25. Mai 1966.
Ja, 65, nicht 60.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne in Frankfurt.
Okay.
Was für Beschränke haben Sie im Moment?
Also, ich habe seit drei Tagen immer wieder mal Husten gehabt.
Jetzt habe ich seit gestern auch Fieber.
Ich habe auch Schmerzen beim Ein- und Ausatmen.
Es kommt jetzt auch viel Schleim raus.
Schleim raus.
Wie ist die Falbe des Ausbruch?
Sie meinen vom Schleim?
Nur Schleim.
Ja, also das ist so gelb-grün.
Mit Husten.
Mit Husten zusammen, ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Husten?
Ja, na klar. Beim Einatmen und beim Husten.
Okay.
Ja, die oft, wo sind Sie?
Also, das ist über den ganzen Tag verteilt.
Auch nachts, das stört mich beim Schlafen.
Nachts.
Haben Sie Luft noch?
Ja, seit gestern merke ich, dass es ein bisschen knapp wird.
Können Sie Flach legen, ohne Luft noch zu bekommen?
Ja, das geht.
Mit Flach legen habe ich kein Problem.
Wie gesagt, nur, dass ich dann die Husterei, die Schmerzen,
da wache ich dann immer wieder auf.
Haben Sie die Werksperrung?
Ja, seit gestern, wie gesagt.
Ich habe es gemessen.
39 Grad.
Du schmunt, oder?
Wie meinen Sie das? Fieber meinen Sie?
Ja.
Ja, ich habe da so einen Stirnthermometer,
hat dich mir geholt.
Ist so ein elektronisches Gerät, damit habe ich es gemessen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schüttersprache?
Wie meinen Sie das jetzt?
Ja, ich habe Pitchnast geschwitzt.
Ich hatte Fieber gehabt, aber sonst habe ich so etwas nicht.
Haben Sie Elbrichen oder Übelkeit?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Duschwein?
Und Sie haben Schlafstören wegen Gusten?
Ja, wie gesagt, seit ein paar Tagen,
jetzt, wo das Husten mehr geworden ist,
mache ich dann immer wieder auf wegen Schmerzen
und wegen Hustenreiz.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder was hinlassen?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Nein, ist alles okay.
Wie ist Ihre Fetiz?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Also seit drei Tagen mag ich gar nichts essen,
aber sonst habe ich einen guten Appetit.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Beim Husten haben Sie andere Beschwerden.
Nur Schmerzen beim Brust?
Nein, außer Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck,
da ist auch immer ein bisschen Blut mit dabei,
wenn ich da etwas abpust, aber das ist alles.
Sie haben Blut im Schrenner.
Wenn ich in der Auswurf komme,
ist da auch ein bisschen Blut mit dabei.
Herr Müller, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Z.B. Zuckerkrankheit, Asthma oder Bluthochdruck?
Also Zuckerkrankheit habe ich nicht.
Asthma ist mir nicht bekannt.
Bluthochdruck, mein Haushalt sagt,
der sei ein bisschen hoch
und ich muss so eine Tablette einnehmen.
Ich glaube, die nennt sich Ramiglich.
Können Sie sich ändern, wie die Dosierung ist?
Dosierung, ich glaube, da steht 5 oder so drauf.
Einmal oder?
Ja, ich will nur einmal morgens sein.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Schwerere oder böse Artikel?
Die andere Erkrankungen sind wenig bekannt.
Nehmen Sie außerbrennlich andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Operiert, ich glaube, als Kind habe man Medemandeln rausgenommen.
Noch etwas?
Nein, sonst ist mir nicht bekannt.
Wie ist die Allergie?
Paprika.
Wie aussagt sich die Allergie?
Ich darf keine Paprika, wenn ich das esse, kriege ich Luftnot,
Juckreiz und einen heftigsten Ausschlag am gesamten Körper.
Was meinen Sie mit dem Status?
Haben Sie alle Impfungen bekommen,
gegen Kindheit und abgel gegen Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona habe ich mich zweimal impfen lassen.
Kindimpfungen, ja, das, was damals üblich war,
habe ich damals bekommen, ja.
Wie rauchst du die Zigaretten?
Ob ich rauche, ja, schon seit meinem 15. Lebensjahr.
Seit 15.
Ja.
Wie oft, wie viel?
Momentan sind es zwar weniger geworden,
aber man kann schon sagen, eine Packung am Tag.
Ja, und wie kann sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ganz selten, Alkohol mag ich nicht so.
Was meinen Sie mit Selten?
Bitte noch mal, ich habe die nicht verstanden.
Selten, also kaum, kaum heißt,
vielleicht ein, zweimal im Jahr oder so.
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Ich muss auch diese Frage stellen,
nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, ja.
Nee, mit Drogen habe ich nichts damit.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronischen
oder schweren Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie mit der Familie,
meine Frau oder, wenn meinen Sie damit?
Ich meine Vater, Ihre Vater, Mutter und Schwester.
Also verwandt dem einen Sie?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, nee.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist fünf Jahre jünger als ich.
Und?
Gesund.
Dumm geht gut, dem fehlt nichts.
Und was ist Ihr Beruf, Herr Herr?
Ich bin Werkzeugmechaniker.
Werkzeugmechaniker?
Mechaniker.
Haben Sie Stress beim Arbeit?
Ob die Arbeit stressig ist,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Sind Sie erhaltet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Seit ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Okay.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau, oder?
Ja, wir leben gemeinsam, ja, zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn und einen Tochter.
Ja, ja.
Und so weit ich diese Analysegespräch abgeschlossen habe,
gibt es noch etwas,
das Sie mir sagen möchten
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzubeugen?
Nein, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Ist das so etwas wie die Lungenentzündung
oder muss ich mir das Sorgen machen?
Weil das Blut hat mich schon ein bisschen erschreckt.
Ja, Herr, es ist blutbrüch.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie Angst haben.
Aber konkret zu sagen, was Sie haben,
müssen wir eine Versuchung machen.
Ja, bitte warten.
Okay, okay, gut.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Ja, klar.
Ich möchte wissen, ob unser Patient
früher ähnliche Beschwerden hatten.
Ne, früher hatte er sowas nicht gehabt.
Und Geruch und Geschmack sind Verlust hat?
Ne, momentan nicht, ne.
Okay, danke.
Bitte, was machen wir jetzt?
Ja, können wir weiter?
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne einen Patientin,
über einen Patientin berichten,
haben Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, ich habe einen.
Der Patient heißt Claes-Joghain-Nülle.
Sieht 50 Jahre aus.
175 cm groß und 85 kg groß.
Schwär?
1,75 kg groß und 85 kg schwer.
Schwär.
Er stellte sich bei uns wegen Pusten
seit 3 Tagen vor.
Die habe Genp-Grün-Sputum.
Er habe Piber seit gestern 39 Grad.
Er bildete das,
dass er das Pneu beim Einatmen
und Schmerz,
durchschmerz habe.
Er fügte hinzu,
dass er das Pusten,
dass er gerade den ganzen Tag Pusten habe.
Deswegen habe er Schlafstöre.
Die vegetative Animesin
ist unabhängig,
bis auf Inappetenz seit 3 Tagen.
Er macht noch 5 kg morgens.
Er hat noch 5 kg morgens.
und er sauge seit ihr 15 Jahre und eine Packung am Tag.
Er saugt seit seinem 15. Lebensjahr.
Er trinkt gelegentlich und selten.
Gelegentlich ist ein falscher Begriff.
Gelegentlich bedeutet, dass sie öfters im Jahr oder in der Woche trinken.
Man muss da schon den Unterschied kennen. Selten.
Wer hat gesagt, wieder ein, zwei Mal im Jahr.
Das ist selten, fast gar nichts.
Wenn man gelegentlich, gelegentlicher Trinker bedeutet,
einmal die Woche, zweimal die Woche vielleicht oder zu Feiertagen.
Das sind Gelegenheitstrinker.
Man unterscheidet den regelmäßigen Trinker, den Gelegenheitstrinker
oder den niedrinker, selten Trinker.
Das muss man auseinanderhalten, sonst macht man Fehler.
Danke.
Drückenkonsum wurden verleint.
Die Familienanalyse sei unaufgleichs.
Er sei Werkzeugmechaniker.
Er sei verheiratet, seit 20 Jahren.
Er hatte zwei Kinder.
Aufgrund der Analyse habe ich einen Perkakt auf Bronschitis.
Als Differenzweltjagdnose kommen Bronsche.
Was kommt als Differenzweltjagdnose?
Phenomonie.
Wie würden Sie den Unterschied machen oder erkennen
zwischen einer Phenomonie und einer Bronschitis?
Phenomonie sind in angolieren Bereich.
Nein, ich meine jetzt gar nicht so.
Pathophysiologisch oder radiologisch.
Als Kliniker, als Arzt vor Ort, können Sie ganz schnell,
einfach durch kleinste Maßnahmen,
können Sie schon eigentlich einordnen, ob das eine Phenomonie ist
oder eine Bronschitis ist?
Erst mal trockenen Husten.
Ja, muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Das kann auch eine Bakterielle Bronschitis sein.
Aber vom Untersuchungsbefund her, Sie sind Kliniker.
Sie sind Assistenzarzt.
Und der Patient stellt sich bei Ihnen vor.
Was machen Sie also, wenn er zu Ihnen kommt?
Sie machen ja nicht nur ein Gespräch mit ihm.
Sie untersuchen den ja auch noch, oder?
Ja, und wie untersuchen Sie den?
Ich werde abhören.
Ja, jetzt haben Sie ihn abgehört.
Was hören Sie denn?
Wo hören Sie das?
Bei Phenomonie kann ich Rassel hören.
Was hören Sie bei Rassel?
Rasselgeräusche.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wo hören Sie die Rasselgeräusche?
Untenbereich.
Unten, oder wie sagt man, medizinisch, in basalen Abschälen?
Ja.
Und bei Bronschitis, wo hören Sie das meistens?
Bei Husten.
Die Krankheit liegt in Bronschen.
Ja, über den größeren Atemwegen.
Das heißt, mitten zwischen den Rippenarealen, also über der Werbesäule.
Wenn Sie da abhören, hören Sie dann, was hören Sie bei einer Bronschitis meistens?
Stridor.
Ja, oder was noch?
Man sagt, ein verschärftes Atemgeräusch.
Man hört dann so richtig die Luft da durchjagen, so zwischen.
Und manchmal auch so grobblasige Rgs, sagt man, keine feuchten oder grobblasige Rgs.
Warum?
Weil manchmal auf dem Bronchen Schleim oder Schwellungen da sind,
die die Luft zum Vibrieren bringen.
Und dann hört man das direkt.
Wenn man in der Peripherie, in den basalen Abschnitten oder im Mittellappenbereich,
hört man selten etwas.
Und man sagt, bei der Pneumonie, was für Rasselgeräusche sind denn das?
Bei der Pneumonie.
Was für Rasselgeräusche.
Man unterscheidet der Rasselgeräusche in Trockenen, in Feuchten.
Und die Feuchten unterscheidet man ja auch nochmal in feinblasige oder grobblasige.
Das Hauptmerkmal einer Pneumonie sind feinblasige Rasselgeräusche.
Das sind sehr, sehr wichtige Kennzeichen.
Die muss man schon wissen, wenn man von einer Pneumonie spricht.
Und als Kliniker, als jemand, der mit seinem Stethoscope
und den Patienten auch noch auskultiert, abhört,
der kann dann eigentlich relativ rasch zuordnen,
ob jemand den Verdacht auf eine Pneumonie hat
oder ob das eher doch eine Bronchitis ist.
Und dieser Mensch, der gibt etwas an, der hat Schmerzen angegeben.
Beim Ein- und Ausatmen hat der Schmerzen.
Das ist bei Bronchitis selten.
Meistens haben die Leute die Schmerzen angeben, immer eine Pneumonie.
Warum?
Weil diese Pneumonien meistens immer eine begleitte Pleuritis erfolgen.
Die Pleuratis entzündet sich ein bisschen.
Beim Ein- und Ausatmen reibt es, dann tut es den weh.
Das sind Hinweise, die sie auf ihre Diagnose immer hinlenken sollen.
Wichtig ist Fieber.
Produktiver Husten, vor allem Geldgrün nicht,
das für eine aktuelle Komponente spricht.
Er hat ein bisschen Blut mit dabei.
Die Husterei geht schon seit einer gewissen Zeit.
Der Mann hat das vorher nie gehabt.
Also muss das etwas Akutes sein.
Jetzt haben Sie denn verdacht, dass er eine Pneumonie hat.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihm?
Gut, kulturell, möglich und dorax.
Sie sind im Krankenhaus, in der Notaufnahme.
Jetzt müssen Sie mit diesen Patienten.
Das muss systematisch erfolgen.
Nicht einfach kalt und quer,
sondern das muss für Sie einen gewissen Ablauf haben,
gewisse Regeln einhalten.
Sie fangen einfach mit dem einfachsten an.
Während der Mann bei Ihnen sitzt, nehmen Sie Blut ab.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Beim Blut abnehmen nehmen Sie auch gleich Blutkulturen mit ab.
Weil er Fieber gehabt hat.
Dafür spricht das,
der könnte eine Bakterie mehr haben.
Bakterien in der Blutkultur, die zu Fieber geführt haben.
Wie oft muss man bei solchen Leuten Blutkulturen abnehmen?
Wie oft?
Wenn ich schon so frage, 2-mal mindestens.
Bei jedem Fieberanstieg oder mindestens 2-mal Blutkulturen abnehmen.
Wenn man Blutkulturen abnimmt, besteht das aus einer Flasche AR-Robbe
und einer Flasche an AR-Robbe.
Das müssen 2-paar Blutkulturflaschen sein.
Wenn da nämlich Bakterie mehr hat,
einen Wachstum von Bakterien in der Blutkultur hat,
dann können Sie ja fast eine Sepsis kodieren.
Dafür ist das dann notwendig.
Weil die Voraussetzung, dass man eine Sepsis kodieren kann,
eine der Voraussetzungen ist,
dass 2-paar Blutkulturen abgenommen sein müssen.
Also Blut abnehmen, normal, Routine-Labor.
Was gehört mit dazu?
In der Routine Blutentnahme.
Was würden Sie bei diesen Menschen alles mit abnehmen kontrollieren?
Beim Blutabnehmen, Blut-Labor.
Ich würde Entzündungszeichen kontrollieren.
Ja, wirklich ist das gängig.
CRP, Blut-Denkung, Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, macht man nicht immer.
Das ist meistens nicht immer notwendig.
Und Lyokositz-Sale?
Ja, was man sagt, einfach die Groben.
Sie bestimmen Elektrolyte,
Retentionparameter, Nierenretentionparameter.
Die Leberwerte kontrollieren Sie.
Und die Entzündungsparameter.
Das ist im Serum.
Und dann kontrollieren Sie noch sein Blutbild.
Worauf achten Sie da beim Blutbild?
Man bestimmt ja alles auf einmal.
Aber worum geht es da?
Wo nachguckt man den Blutbild?
Nach der Leukozytose.
CRP-Erhöhung plus Leukozytose
spricht für eine bakterielle Infektion meistens.
Das sind zwei wichtige Parameter,
die Sie in meinem Auge behalten müssen.
Wenn der Mensch keinen Appetit hat,
wenig getrunken hat,
dann gucken Sie nach den Nierenretentionwerden,
ob der zum Beispiel exekiert ist,
ob der Flüssigkeit braucht,
ob sie Infusionen aufschreiben müssen.
Also Blut haben Sie jetzt abgenommen.
Was können Sie in der Notaufnahme direkt noch tun?
Ganz logisch denken.
Jemand kommt mit Hustern, Auswurf und sagt,
der hat auch ein bisschen Luftnot dabei.
Was können Sie machen?
Ganz einfach.
In jeder Notaufnahme gibt es einen Monitor.
Und zu den Vitalparameter.
Was man Blutdruck kontrolliert,
Herzfrequenz kontrolliert.
Und man kann auch auf die Hand,
und man kann auch überall jetzt ganz leicht Sättigung messen.
Wie ist die Sauerstoffsättigung?
Ist die über 90, ist die unter 90?
Ist der so stabil, dass er auf die Normalstation kann?
Oder ist er so schlecht,
dass sich eventuell auf die Überwachung
oder auf eine Intensivstation nehmen muss?
Das alles,
müssen Sie ganz schnell Schritt für Schritt abklären.
Wenn Sie merken, die Sättigung ist doch deutlich runtergegangen,
keine 95, keine 94, sondern gerade mal 90 rum,
dann machen Sie noch etwas,
dann machen Sie eine Blutgasanalyse.
Dann gucken Sie, wie viel Sauerstoff nimmt er denn auf?
Hat der ein Sättigungsproblem, hat der ein Aufnahmeproblem?
Oder ist der vielleicht obstruktiv?
Der Mann hat geraucht, der raucht noch.
Obwohl er es nicht weiß, kann er eine COPD haben.
Und bei einer Infektion eskaliert das Ganze.
Dann müssen Sie nämlich entscheiden,
ob Sie anti-obstruktiv noch behandeln müssen oder nicht.
Und dann kommt als letzter Schritt,
damit Sie das Ganze perfekt haben,
schicken Sie diesen Menschen nochmal zum Röntgen.
Ganz zum Schluss.
Sie haben Ihre Aufgaben alle erledigt.
Jetzt schicken Sie ihn zum Röntgen.
Und der Radiologe ruft sie an und sagt,
der hat rechtsbasal ein ausgeprägtes Infektrat mit einem Begleiterguss.
Dann sagen Sie, gehen Sie zum Patienten hin.
Und jetzt verkünden Sie eben, was er hat.
Bevor Sie ihn irgendwo hinverlegen.
Heutzutage muss man wieder nochmal vorsichtig sein.
Dazu kommen wir aber gleich.
Obwohl der Mann zweimal geimpft ist,
die Kollegin, die vorhin gefragt hat,
die hat nach gewissen Hinweisen gefragt.
Geschmacksverlust oder Geruchsverlust.
Was hat sie damit bezwegt?
Corona.
Obwohl man doppelt geimpft sein kann,
kann man trotzdem Corona infiziert sein.
Und deshalb müssen Sie heutzutage auch noch einen Test machen.
Und da dieser Mensch ambulant kommt,
müssen Sie ihn zunächst auf eine Verdachtstation tun.
Sie können ihn nicht auf eine Normastation tun.
Es gibt in den Krankenhäusern sogenannte Covid-Verdachtstationen.
Und nur, wenn das dort ausgeschlossen ist,
dann werden sie auf die normale Peripherastation verlegt.
Aber die Bedingung ist, dass er keinen Sauerstoff braucht,
dass die Sättigung gutes, normal ist.
Das ist ja nicht respiratorisch eingebrochenes.
Das Sie dann sagen können, das sieht nicht wie eine Covid-Infektion aus.
Aber bis zum Ausschluss einer Covid-Infektion
wird er als Verdachtfall geführt.
Und wenn morgen übermorgen der Nachweis kommt,
dass er negativ ist, kann er auf die Normastation weiterfällig werden.
Jetzt haben Sie als Art sozusagen die gesamte Diagnostik gemacht.
Und jetzt müssen Sie alles mit dem Patienten besprechen, ihm erklären.
Jetzt gehen Sie zu ihm hin und erklären ihm, was er hat,
was Sie mit ihm machen werden
und wie lange er vielleicht im Krankenhaus verbringen muss.
Dann erzählen Sie mal, den Patienten nochmal erzählen.
Was hat er, was hat sich herausgestellt
und was machen Sie mit ihm
und wie lange wird der voraussichtlich da bleiben?
Ich bin der Patient und Sie erzählen mir nochmal, was ich jetzt habe.
Herr Müller, jetzt werde ich Ihnen
Vitalparameter überprüfen
und Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Wir Brut abnehmen.
Dann sehen wir, ob die Entzündungszeichen nachweisbar sind.
Und nach laufs Ergebnisse können wir...
Was haben wir alles gemacht?
Wir haben alles schon gemacht.
Sie haben die Blutergebnisse da, Sie haben das Brandkind schon gemacht.
Sie haben auch die Sättigung gemacht.
Jetzt erklären Sie ihm zu welchem Entschluss,
zu welcher Schlussfolgerung Sie gekommen sind,
was der jetzt für eine Erkrankung hat.
Er hat ja gefragt, warum ist er da,
ist das etwas Gefährliches oder nicht.
Jetzt haben Sie alles gemacht.
Und jetzt sagen Sie mir, was ich habe.
Ich bin mit Husten bekommen, Fieber.
Was ist denn die Ursache dafür?
Das erzählen Sie mir jetzt mal, verständlich.
Nicht medizinische Begriffe,
sondern Sie müssen es mir verständlich wiedergeben.
Herr Müller, wir haben eine Verdacht.
Wir haben eine Verdacht auf, nicht Verdacht.
Wir haben eine Diagnose gestattet.
Wir haben Pneumonie und...
Was ist eine Pneumonie?
Pneumonie bedeutet eine lungen Krankheit.
Und ohne Behandlung kann es gefährlich sein.
Was heißt eine lungen Krankheit?
Ist das tuberkulose?
Was ist das?
Nein, eine...
Wahrscheinlich ist das eine bakterielle Erkrankung.
Entzündung.
Man nennt das auf Deutsch Lungenentzündung.
Pneumonie heißt Lungenentzündung.
Und wie Sie es gesagt haben,
das hört sich an wie eine bakterielle Lungenentzündung.
Entzündung.
Sie müssen ein paar Tage bei uns bleiben.
Was schätzen Sie, wie lange Sie dort halten müssen?
Wie viele Tage mindestens?
Mindestens fünf oder sechs Tage.
Fünf Tage mindestens, ja.
Sie müssen die Antibiotiktherapie führen.
Ja, kann ich die denn nicht als Tabletten nehmen?
Warum muss ich dann im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Die Aufgrund der Stadion der Erkrankung
müssen wir die Medikamente verabreichen.
Was ist der Grund, warum Sie in Stationen aufnehmen müssen?
Es gibt Musikofaktoren.
Rauchen.
Rauchen ist zum Beispiel ein Risikofaktor.
Das könnte schon eine Begründung sein,
dass Sie in Stationen aufnehmen.
Was aber auch noch, der hat ein Radiologisch,
ein Begleiterguss.
Das kann auch im schlimmsten Fall ein Empirren sein.
Was Sie nicht wissen können.
Das kann man Ihnen nicht einfach mit Antibiotikertabletten
beantragen.
Er hat Luftnot und Schmerzen.
Deshalb müssen Sie ihn intravenös-antibiotisch behandeln.
Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung.
Wir müssen Ihnen mindestens fünf Tage Antibiotika
über die Wehne geben.
Dann frage ich mal ganz dumm,
was sind Antibiotika?
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Antibiotika ist eine Medikamente gegen
Entzündung Erreger.
Ja, wirken die auch gegen Viren.
Weil Viren sind ja auch Entzündungserreger.
Ja, aber das sind die Antibiotika
gegen Vakterien.
Erreger.
Erklärn Sie einfach ganz banal.
Das sind Medikamente,
die das Wachstum von Bakterien hemmen
oder Bakterien abtöten können.
Das wollen die Prüfer manchmal wissen.
Dass man denen das verständlich erklärt.
Woher soll ein Laie wissen, was Antibiotika sind?
Man hört einfach, aber die sprechen ja von Bakterizid
oder Bakteriostatisch.
Aber das muss man denen Deutsch erklären können.
Manche wollen wissen, hat der das dann verstanden
und sprichte das nur, weil er auswendig gelernt hat.
Medikamente, die Bakterien im Wachstum hemmen
oder aber auch abtöten können.
Dadurch kann dann der Körper die Entzündung bekämpfen
und die Symptome gehen wieder zurück.
Gut, also Antibiotika.
Machen wir parallel noch etwas?
Oder kriegt er nur IV-Antibiotika?
Wir geben dem noch ein bisschen Schmerzmittel.
Was geben Sie denen denn?
Schmerzmittel.
Was geben Sie denen dann an Schmerzmittel?
Ibuprofen.
Oder, was noch, das kann man auch noch nehmen.
Voltauen können Sie nehmen, Ibuprofen können Sie nehmen.
Das sind die nicht sterile,
sterilisierenden Antirolmatika, die auch teilweise anti-entzündlich
wirken können.
Das ist das allerwichtige, anti-entzündliche.
Die würde ich dann schon nehmen.
Parallel dazu IV-Antibiotika.
Je nachdem, wie seine Nierenretentionswerte sind,
ob er ein Krekanstieg hat oder nicht,
vielleicht auch vorsichtig bis in Flüssigkeit.
Und nach zwei Tagen vielleicht nochmal
vielleicht nochmal die Entzündungswerte kontrollieren und wenn die Werte nach vier,
fünf Tagen deutlich rückläufig sind, kann man das die Therapie dann auf Tabletten umstellen
und ihn dann wieder nach Hause schicken. Was müssen sie aber machen? Sie müssen regelmäßig
die Lunge abhören, ob der Egoist noch da ist, ob sie dann noch was hören oder ob die Rasselgeräusche
weniger geworden sind oder nicht. Und ob ihre Therapie angesprochen hat, können sie auch
andersweilig noch kontrollieren, Verlaufskontrollieren sagen wir, wenn sein Fieber aufhört. Wenn er
kein Fieber mehr hat, wenn sein Husten weniger wird, wenn der Auswurf weniger wird, dann greift
ihre Therapie. Gut. Und wenn ich jetzt frage, welches Antibiotikum geben Sie ihm denn?
Würde ich nicht machen, würde ich nicht machen. Weil Sie müssen als Arzt in der Notaufnahme
folgenden Unterschied machen. Ist das ein Risikopatient? Risikopatient heißt,
ist der vielleicht immungeschwächt, hat der Krebstherapie laufen, hat der vielleicht eine
immunsuppressive Therapie, ist das jemand, der recidivierend irgendwelche Entzündungen im
Respirationstrakt hat, wie eine COPD oder Asthmatika oder eine andere Lüngung,
Gerüst der Erkrankung, nimmt der Steroide ein, dann haben Sie recht, dann würde ich schon
etwas breiteres Spektrum Antibiotikum geben. Aber der Mann ist doch kerngesund, auch wenn er raucht,
hat keine COPD und das ist eine ambulant erworbene Pneumonie. Das reicht einfach
ein Antibiotikum, Amoxicilin. Penicillin reicht da völlig aus. Aminopenicilin, Amoxicilin,
man kann vielleicht das weitergehen und sagen, man kann auch ein Betalactamase mit dazu nehmen,
nicht Piperazilin, sondern Sultamicilin, kann man ihm geben und wenn man dann sagt,
der hat geraucht, der könnte auch so ein bisschen noch zusätzlich Probleme haben,
kann man ihm noch ein Makulett mit dazu nehmen für 2-3 Tage. Aber das ist auch alles Zerfallosporin
oder Flurchinolone, direkt von Anfang an würde ich nicht geben. Die sind auch problematisch,
weil die auch zu vielen Resistenzen führen. Mittlerweile dreht man das Ganze wieder zurück
und sagt, mit den einfachsten Medikamenten beginnen und die als Reserve Antibiotika zurückhalten.
Und deshalb, dann wird der natürlich der Prüfer fragen, welche Formen von Pneumonien kennen
Sie denn? Wie würden Sie Pneumonien einteilen? Ja, sehr gut, aber fangen Sie doch mit
der einfachsten an. Wo bekommen die meisten Menschen ihre Pneumonien? Ambulant, ambulant,
erworbene Pneumonien. Und die nennt man dann Nosokomial, wie Sie es gesagt haben. Und dann gibt es aber
nur welche, die kommen aus Pflegeheimen oder so. Wie nennt man die denn dann? Ja, das ist so ein Begriff,
dass sich jetzt so langsam in die Literatur hineinmogelt, sag ich mal. Man spricht von
institutionell erworbenen Pneumonien. Das sind ja keine Menschen, die von zu Hause kommen,
sondern das sind ja teils stationäre Sachen. Krankenhaus ist etwas anderes als ein Pflegeheim.
Man kann dann nicht sagen Nosokomial, aber es ist auch nicht ambulant. Deswegen hat man
Institutionen gesagt, pflegerische, halbpflegerische, halbstationäre Anstalten, die dann zu einer
Pneumonie führen. Und interstiziell? Interstiziell, sehr gut. Das ist schon mal sehr,
sehr wichtig. Und radiologisch kann man ja auch nochmal unterteilen. Es gibt die sogenannte
Luberpneumonie und Lappenpneumonien. Die kann man ja auch. Und je nachdem, ob das eine
sekundäre Sache ist, zum Beispiel, ob jemand auf der Intensivstation nach einer Intubation,
nach einer Respiratortherapie sowas bekommt oder nicht, das ist wiederum eine ganz andere
Situation. Und davon abhängig müssen Sie dann Ihre Antibiotika-Wahl treffen. Je risikoreicher,
desto stärker muss dann Ihr Antibiotikum sein oder desto mehr Kombinationen müssen Sie dann
überlegen. Aber die einfacher in der Ambulante das Ganze geht, können Sie ein ganz einfaches
Aminopenicillin geben. Was ist denn der häufigste Erreger, was bei ambulanten Pneumonien zu einer
Lungenentzündung, zu einer Pneumonie führt? Ja, Pneumokokken sagt der Deutsch. Pneumokokken.
Und wenn wir schon dabei sind, kann man sich denn nicht dagegen impfen? Ja, gibt es gegen diese Krankheiten
Impfung für alte Menschen oder Risiko unter Risikomenschen? Ja, also Risikomenschen oder Menschen
unter Risiko, denen wird sogar die Impfung gegen die Pneumonie, gegen die Pneumokokkenpneumonie
empfohlen. Das kann man sicherlich machen. Und meistens wird das mit der Influenza gemeinsam
gemacht. Die Hausärzte machen das und das ist nichts Schlechtes. Ich habe viele Menschen gesehen,
die profitieren davon. Gut. Also wichtig ist der Ablauf in der Notaufnahme, dass Sie einfach
Ihren Ablauf koordinieren, dass Sie einfach im Kopf Schritt für Schritt weiter voran arbeiten,
dass Sie schon mal Ihre These haben. Da besteht der Verdacht auf eine Pneumonie und dann müssen
Sie schnell handeln. Wenn jemand mit Fieber kommt, mit einer Lungenentzündung kommt,
dann können Sie den nicht stundenlang in der Notaufnahme warten lassen, bevor Sie dem ein
Antibiotikum geben. Vor allem, wenn es jemand ist, der immunsuppressiv behandelt ist, da können
manchmal Stunden lebensrettend sein. Da müssen Sie ganz schnell handeln. Fragen, wenn Sie ganz
schnell fertig sind, dann sofort Blutabnehmen, Blutkultur abnehmen. Sie haben eine Braunülle
gelegt und dann hängen Sie sofort ein Antibiotikum dran, warten nicht bis das Röntgen gelaufen ist.
Nicht warten. Das ist falsch. Manche Kollegen machen das immer noch in der Notaufnahme. Dann
verlieren diese Menschen sehr viel Zeit. Wenn der Fieber gehabt hat, kann er auch eine
Sepsis haben und die Sepsis kann gefährlich werden. Je früher man mit dem Antibiotikum
reingeht, desto besser kann man diesem Menschen da helfen. Also ganz schnell handeln. Immer
zack, zack, schnell, schnell. Blutabnehmen, Braunülle legen, Blutkultur abnehmen, sofort
Antibiotikum bei der Schwester Oran oder im System reingeben, dass dann das Antibiotikum
schnell kommt. Während das Antibiotikum reinläuft, kann man das Röntgen dann eingeben. Der
Patient wird zum Röntgen abgeholt. Wenn er dann wieder da ist, wissen Sie dann,
aha, der hat eine ambulante Pneumonie. Ich habe einen Infiltrat und dann schreiben wir alles
mögliche noch auf, bisschen Schmerzmittel noch da rein, bisschen Infusion noch da rein und dann
vielleicht zweimal am Tag Sauerstoffsetigung kontrollieren, Blutdruck kontrollieren und
dann tun Sie den normalerweise auf die Normaustation während der Corona-Pandemie schicken
Sie denn aber erst mal auf die Verdachtstützung. Und wenn dort Covid ausgeschlossen ist, dann
geht der auf die Normaustützung. So hat der Ablauf klar. Bei einer Bronchitis müssen Sie niemanden
aufnehmen. Die Bronchitis kann man auch ambulant behandeln. Wenn jemand kommt in die Notaufnahme,
der hat ein bisschen geldlichen Auswurf, aber nur einen Husten, können Sie dem auch sagen,
nehmen Sie Paracetamol ein. Ich schreibe Ihnen hier ein Antibiotikum auf, nehmen Sie die Tabletten ein.
Wenn es nach drei, vier Tagen nicht besser wird, gehen Sie zu Ihrem Haushalt. Bronchitis und Pneumonie,
das ist der Unterschied. Wenn Sie eine Pneumonie haben, müssen Sie ihn aufnehmen. Dann können
Sie nicht einfach nach Hause schicken. Ja, so weit verstanden? Ja, noch Fragen? Ich bin
auch nicht so detailliert. Ja, kann ja sein. Wir haben das jahrelang trainiert. Wir wissen ja damit
umzugehen. Und deswegen ist es gut, dass man das praktische Einfachen wiederholt, dass man dann
auch so ein Bild hat, wie man vorzugehen. Ein Chirurg muss das nicht unbedingt kennen in der
Notaufnahme oder einen Ohrarzt oder einen Augenarzt. Aber in der Notaufnahme sitzen nun mal
Internisten meistens, die mit so etwas zu tun haben und die sollten den Ablauf schon kennen.
Ja, und man hat noch ein weiteres Problem, dass regional sagt man unterschiedliche Länder manchmal
mit den Therapien auch ein bisschen unterschiedliche umgehen. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass in der Türkei die Standards so ein bisschen anders sind als hier, zum Beispiel was
Antibiotika angeht. Vieles wird gleich sein, aber dass die dann dort direkt mit stärkeren
Antibiotika reingehen, mag ja sein. Es gibt hier auch welche Krankenhäuser, die geben direkt gleich
irgendwie Piperazilientazobaktam oder ähnliches. Davon halten wir nicht viel. Es gibt die
sogenannten Hygieniker im Haus und es gibt mittlerweile auch so etwas wie ein
Antibiotik Stewardship, sagt man mittlerweile. Das sind so speziell ausgebildete Ärzte, die im
Krankenhaus den Antibiotika Einsatz koordinieren und auch regeln sollen, damit nicht unnötig viel
Reserveantibiotikum verbraucht wird, was zu Resistenzbildung führt. Und deshalb gibt es
die Empfehlung, so niedrig wie möglich mit den Reserveantibiotika reingehen. Und man muss
dann deshalb wissen, was ist das für eine Infektion? Noch so komial, ambulant, kommt
er aus dem Pflegeheim, ist das ein Risikopatient, ist das eventuell ein resistenter
Keim, haben andere noch Fragen?
Sie sprechen ganz flüssig hier gut und hier hören sie ganz, so älterntauschen,
sie sprechen ganz gut. Danke schön, dass ihr das unterrichtet.
Soweit verstanden, alles? Ja, genau.
Gut, vielen Dank. Wenn keine Fragen sind, wie lange haben wir es jetzt gemacht? Eine
Stunde ist doch gut, super.
Beimen kommen oder Pflegebedürftig sind oder andere Probleme haben, das ist wiederum
eine Sondersituation, aber so bei normaler ambulanter Pneumonie ist eine
Kleptielle nicht zu erwarten. Da wird natürlich in Amoxi-Penicillin nicht
ausreichen, da müssen sie natürlich mit etwas Breiterem reingehen.
Da können sie auch einen Piperazilienter zu Bactam geben oder aber auch
irgendein Zephalosporin, der zweiten bis dritten Generation, das muss man dann
abhängig machen, je nachdem, was da reinkommt. Aber ich würde in dem Falle
immer den Verdacht auf eine ambulante erworbene Pneumonie immer mit, was weiß ich,
Unacitta, also Sultamicillin beginnen oder Ampicillin und wenn die
Blutkultur aber zeigt, dass dort doch Klebsiellen vorhanden sind,
nachgewiesen sind und wenn das CRP nicht besser wird, die Klinik nicht besser
wird, dann muss man natürlich das Antibiotikum anpassen. Aber das ist eher
eine Rarität, das sieht man nicht so heißig.
Dankeschön. Okay. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.